Ця, на перший погляд, непримітна вулиця
уславилась не лише на весь Берлін,
але й далеко за його межами.
Потсдамер штрассе –
приклад вдалої комерціалізації міського простору,
коли нові магазини, галереї та дорогі ресторани
не витісняють з кварталу старіші
та значно простіші крамниці та бари,
а живуть поруч з ними.
Для Берліна це болюча тема.
Мешканці не найбагатшого міста Німеччини
нервово сприймають прихід в столицю “великих грошей”.
Однією з перших відкрила тут свій бутік
дизайнерка британського походження Фіона Беннетт.
Вона каже: центральна частина Берліна
втратила свій шарм.
Мені більше не подобалася тамтешня атмосфера,
мої клієнти не хотіли туди їздити,
не могли знайти парковку,
в центрі стало забагато людей,
загалом вся атмосфера змінилась не на краще.
Стало схоже на Діснейленд,
таке штучне, не автентичне.
В пошуках місця для ательє та бутІка
вона приїхала на Потсдамер штрассе
неподалік від центру Західного Берліна.
Вулиця сподобалась їй інтернаціональним характером
та доброзичливими сусідами.
Толерантність –
та риса, яка робила наше місто кращим.
І саме через неї багато хто їде в Берлін –
люди прагнуть вільнішого життя.
Приклад такого підходу - Олівер Мане,
власник двох ресторанів.
Він переїхав до Берліна два роки тому з Гамбурга.
Йому подобається, що тут нові проекти
гарно співіснують зі старими.
Але вулиця змінюється.
Шикарніше, дорожче, вишуканіше.
Але поки ще є ця суміш,
поки традиційні магазини мають шанс на виживання,
поки не сталася
радикальна зміна власності
- для мене це прийнятно.
Гості цього ресторану - люди мистецтва,
клерки, а останнім часом – більше туристів.
Після статті в New York Times вулиця стала відомою
навіть в Америці.
Водночас і тут не все так добре.
Щонайменше раз на тиждень машину Олівера Мане псують –
дряпають, проколюють шини
або б'ють скло.
Він це пояснює поширенням лівих поглядів -
ліві заперечують прогрес в цілому та капіталізм зокрема.
Люди бояться втратити квартири,
бо чим більші прибутки,
тим дорожчі розцінки на оренду житла.
Тож багато хто змушений
переселятися подалі від центру. Нинішній Берлін –
одне з найбідніших міст Німеччини.